[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander I'm the
executive director here at the long now
foundation and as many of you know we
start these talks with a long short a
short film about long term thinking and
tonight's one is one that I've I chose a
long time ago and when waiting for the
perfect the perfect talk to do it in and
while Sarah is going to be speaking
tonight about exoplanets planets in
systems very very far away from ours
this film The Wanderers is a amazing
piece that shows how much more discovery
and exploration we can do of some of the
worlds in the nearer space thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I feel like I should walk on here with
something other than boring old 1g hi
I'm a Stuart brand from the long now
foundation I've learned about planetary
atmospheres in the 70s because Koval
even quarterly which I added then was
the first u.s. publication to publish to
the Gaia hypothesis by Lynn Margulis
and James Lovelock and Jim tells the
origin story of the Gaia hypothesis that
he was working you've been hired by
Viking as a atmospheric chemist who had
developed the electron capture device
that was detecting those own apart
spending and DDT of parts per million
and so on and they asked him to look at
basically spectral information coming
from the atmosphere of Mars and tell
them if there's anything interesting
about it and he said well the
interesting thing about it is it's in
perfect chemical stability which means
there's no life on Mars sorry you're
saying
at which point NASA said that's very
interesting
I'll be quiet about that now
and he was but it made him realize that
the extremely unstable chemistry of
Earth was a signal not only of life but
of some processes he began looking at
and how has become birth system Sciences
looking at the presence or absence of
life on planets there's an atmospheric
issue so it'd be nice to get somebody to
talk about it who's written a book
called exoplanet atmospheres sir seeker
[Music]
thanks Stuart thanks everyone for coming
out well the funny thing about
atmospheres is that even when we think
we understand them in a global sense
there's a lot of small things that don't
always make sense this year in Boston in
winter we got over 100 inches of snow
which for us was great it was a record
but the funny thing is is coming out
here it's way colder than it is in
Boston so here we are with a view of the
night sky and I wanted to just start out
by reminding all of us that every star
in the sky is the Sun and if our Sun has
planets surely all these other stars
should have planets also and they do and
in the last 20 years or so we have found
thousands of lenez and we believe now
that every star in our sky has at least
one planet and planetary systems are
just so common whenever I look up at the
stars I always wonder is there another
planet around that star and are there
any intelligent beings on that other
planet far away looking back at us I
really hope they're out there and I hope
that someday we're gonna find them and
so what we're looking for when we talk
about looking for another planet that
might be like Earth is looking for Earth
a pale blue dot far away and this is
actually a real photograph of Earth by
the Voyager 1 spacecraft this was
orchestrated by Carl Sagan and it was
taken from four billion miles away and
believe it or not most of my work about
atmospheres it is about how to take a
little dot like this whether it's a star
or a planet
and in the future another earth and try
to infer everything possible about that
planet whether there is water on it or
signs of life by way of gases in the
atmosphere that don't belong so what I'm
going to talk about today is what is an
exoplanet when and how will we find
another earth can we go there if we
can't go there why look and by the way
these are the questions that I get asked
most often by people of all walks of
life from children to elderly people to
you know people I meet on the plane to
actually everyone and you know what the
most popular question is it is can we go
there and even when I explained it how
we can't really do that right now
I still get asked it over and over again
even during Q&A so I'm sure some of you
are are wondering about that now to get
started I wanted to leave you with
something to take away when you get home
tonight or in the coming days I want you
to google for eyes on exoplanets and
download this software I didn't write
this I wasn't part of it I just loved it
so much I have a little clip of it to
show you and it starts out here with an
artist's illustration of what we think
our Milky Way galaxy looks like from far
away a galaxy is a collection of bound
stars and our Sun would be about here
with respect to the billions of stars in
our galaxy and this is just a little
clip showing you our Milky Way and these
zooming into where our son is you can
see the stars here and all the
highlighted objects are stars with known
planets the different stars are
different colors red is a small star
yellow would be like our Sun white would
be something brighter than our Sun and
now this clip just keeps zooming in to
our planet Earth it actually also shows
you some spacecraft that are orbiting
our Sun epoxies here you can see Spitzer
and Kepler now you can use the software
and here we're gonna click on the west
coast of north america looking up at the
spring night sky and overlaying the
constellations here actually you could
actually do this now if you download
this software for tonight or anywhere on
earth where it's dark at that present
time and look up at this guy and it'll
show you a real map of the stars now
here it's overlaying the constellations
of course those are not conveniently
drawn for you out in the sky and also
many of the
stars you couldn't see them just with
your naked eye you'd probably need
binoculars or a telescope you can see
this is gonna actually now rotate to
zoom into a very special part of the sky
look at that does anyone know which part
of the sky this is yeah this is the
Kepler space telescopes field of view
and there's such a concentration here
actually no the whole sky really that's
when I said that we think every star in
the sky should have a planet because we
actually know that from a specific
technique called micro lensing but on
the whole there are a lot of planets out
there now the thing that's really nice
about this software is you can actually
use it to search for a planet by name in
case you happen to have a favorite
planet whose name you know
one of the favorites from astronomers or
the public or anyone really is
kepler-186 six and if you zoom on it
it'll actually take you to this in this
real map of the stars where kepler-186
is and you can take a kind of a look at
it and its orbit now this particular
system has several planets but the
reason we're excited about it is the so
called kepler 186f in the planets
habitable zone now here you see the
habitable zone is shaded we don't know
exactly where it is but what the
habitable zone is is it's a region
around a star where if a planet is in
that orbit it will be heated by the star
not too hot and not too cold but just
right for life and now in this movie
clip it'll keep zooming in on kepler
186f but here's where the fine print you
can barely read it it says hypothetical
visualization of planet we don't know
this this is the part we don't know we
know about the real map of the stars but
we don't really see planets in that
level of detail quite yet actually
actually we might never do that in our
lifetimes but that's the software it's
called eyes on exoplanets and you can
spend a lot of time clicking on the
stars and fooling around with it and I
really hope you all are able to do that
but not now during my talk so actually
what I work on is planet atmospheres and
what planets look like from far away and
I write computer code and all my
students also do but before I get to
some more details I wanted to just take
you on a tour of some of our favorite
planets so here's a poster actually
kepler 186f yeah it's a travel poster
it says well kepler-186f
where the grass is always redder on the
other side because kepler-186 is a small
star it's a red dwarf star and some
people actually have worked on this
thinking that perhaps plants and
vegetation is a different color taking
advantage of different wavelengths of
light
that the red star would be brighter at
than our Sun next travel hoster is for
experience the gravity of HD 403 o7g a
super-earth and here they're showing
someone parachuting but here in this
case the planet is has a surface gravity
of about one and a half times the size
of Earth
Kepler relax on Kepler 16b the land of
two sons where your shadow always has
company and in this particular poster is
showing an astronaut on a planet that's
orbiting two suns we call these
circumbinary planets and now we know of
about a dozen of them it's a planet that
orbits two suns and actually as long as
those two suns are close together and
the planet is several times further away
than that distance between the two suns
it should be gravitationally bound and
what I like about this is well science
fiction got some things right one of my
favorite planets is Kepler 10b this is
what we call a hot super earth it is so
close to its Sun that it's it's based on
Kepler's law The Closer planet is to a
star the shorter its orbit the faster it
orbits and this planet orbits orbits the
Sun entirely in less than one Earth Day
is zipping around that Sun the planet is
so close to the Sun that it is heated by
the Sun the surface would be so hot we
think hot enough to melt rock and in
this artist's conception here they're
showing you just that they're cracks and
just it would be like going outside and
instead of seeing a puddle of water it
would be a puddle of of rock only we
could never go there because we would
melt long before we reach the surface
now the last one I'll tell you about is
Gliese 1214 B in this particular one you
can see the nebulosity because the
artists think this was too boring to
just show you the planet with the star
and in this case we actually don't know
much about this particular planet it's
we know about its mass and its size
and we don't know a lot else about it
actually and most of these planets we
just know their mass and size and the
amount of energy reaching the surface
but this what planet is of interest
because it falls in a very intermediate
mass and size range actually it's too
big to be an earth but way too small to
be a Jupiter and even too small to be
like a neptune and what that means is
that this particular object it actually
has no solar system counterpart and we
don't even really know what this planet
is made of Gliese 1214 B it could be a
big rocky planet surrounded by a massive
gas envelope or it could be something we
think about we call it a Waterworld a
planet that would be like one of
Jupiter's icy moons 50% water mass or
more a scaled up version of that and if
this planet was predominately water
actually we think it's pretty close to
the star it's pretty hot that it would
have a thick steam atmosphere and under
that atmosphere wouldn't be a layer of
liquid water but would be a layer of
supercritical water a kind of material
that's not quite a gas not quite a
liquid and that would actually be over a
high Persian of high pressure ice I
would say like ice 9 but no ice 9 was
just a joke in the novel not a joke not
serious but these high-pressure ices is
where water is squeezed together until
it becomes solid so all sorts of
different types of materials inside
planets and could be out there and I
just wanted you to know that there are
lots and lots of planets this graph is
showing you all the planets found by the
Kepler space telescope to date as of
July 2015 and what you're seeing here is
the size relative to earth radius so
Eartha would be here at one earth radius
and at the bottom here it's just telling
you about the planet's orbit orbital
period in days so this would be a planet
of one day out here at 365 you'd have
earth but just look how many there are
there's thousands of planets out there
and those are the only ones we even know
about and I want you to take a look at
this graph and and you can actually
think for a moment and see where are
there them where's the graph that most
dense where are the most points I'm
trying to ask you can you see what is
the most Commons planet size and on this
plot you can see it's sparsely populated
up here in fact so these jupiter-sized
planets are
not nearly as common as planets down the
size of earth or a little bit bigger
actually and this is one of the biggest
findings actually in exoplanets and I'm
guessing you don't hear about this many
of you wouldn't have heard of this at
all but the most common type of planet
out there is something small and this is
really puzzling actually because all the
things that we were taught at least in
planetary science is that the end
product of planet formation should be a
big planet like Jupiter where Jupiter is
born and material creats until it gets
massive enough - like a giant vacuum
cleaner just suck in all the material
around it until it exhausts its feeding
zone and we always believe that the end
product of planet formation would be a
big planet as big as it could possibly
be but in fact it's not true and for
many of these planets in here about two
to three times the size of Earth Neptune
is up here at four or 3di we actually
don't know how those planets formed and
so we're left with this kind of really
big puzzle from exoplanets now out of
all the planets were looking for the
ones we want to find to in the future be
able to search for life on them are the
so-called Goldilocks planets planets
that orbit from the star they're not too
hot not too cold but just right and this
is a little complicated I'll come back
to this a little bit later but it's the
so-called habitable zone or Goldilocks
zone so what is an exoplanet a planet
that orbits the star other than the Sun
thousands of exoplanets are known to
exist and we expect that nearly every
star has a planetary system all right
how and when we find another earth well
it turns out that our earth is very very
hard to find and we actually use this
analogy that looking for an earth would
be like looking for a firefly next to a
searchlight
but that firefly in searchlight would be
thousands of miles away like the
distance from here to Boston usually I'm
working in Reverse I'm usually in the
East Coast I just say it's like looking
here but think about that for a moment a
firefly our earth compared to our Sun is
10 billion times fainter that's such a
huge number and I want you to think
about for a moment what could you in
turn to think of one to ten billion what
could you buy for one dollar it's like
actually not a whole lot nowadays and
now think for a moment
could you get four ten billion I mean
such a huge number our earth is so faint
compared to our Sun that's our analogy
here and I want to tell you a bit about
this picture where a number of years ago
I was consulting for National Geographic
and they actually wanted to take a real
picture of this anyone here who's a
photographer I think you know you don't
really have the dynamic range to detect
the Firefly next to the searchlight they
punched it I think you can see here
Firefly and the first thing I was my job
to tell them what I liked or what I
didn't like or what was right or what
was inaccurate and the first thing I
said which was inaccurate was the
searchlights here look how they're all
together they actually rented the
searchlights and took it to a field and
made this picture and I just said look
we don't see stars like this you never
see four stars together nonetheless I
think you all know what a great
publication National Geographic is and
the photographer's came back and they
were amazed they were so excited jumping
up and down they said well we couldn't
take a picture of the Firefly next to
the searchlight but we could take a
picture of the Firefly in front of the
searchlight and they actually had
inadvertently discovered a whole
different way to find planets we already
knew how to do this but they had found
it on their own
it's called transits and how many of you
have heard of transits okay so I'm gonna
explain to you for those of you who
don't know but basically if you have a
planet going in front of a star instead
of being a one part in ten billion
contrary difference it's only well I
will say only one part in ten thousand
for an earth going in front of the star
it signals one part in ten thousand and
if we can get a big Earth going in front
of a small star then that's only one
part in a thousand and that's a much
easier number to to handle actually for
any kind of measurement and so to tell
you what a transit is and why today
we're always focusing on transits it's
just an easier thing to see than a
planet directly
so here's showing you a planet can you
all see the little planet going in front
of the Sun it's supposed to be earth
size compared to our Sun we don't see
any other stars other than our Sun
spatially resolved like this and there
it is and look at the bottom here
there's a graph of the planet going in
front of the star and when the planet
finishes going in front of the star that
drop in brightness goes away
going to show that to you one more time
because this is actually the way that we
find most planets today there find by
the so-called transit method and just in
case this plot made it look too easy you
know what it's at least 10,000 hours per
planet yes because we look at lots we
meaning the whole community has lots of
data looking at hundreds of thousands of
stars searching all of them just for
this very special signature of a planet
going in front of a star that works on
the right time scale and is the right
drop in brightness and even then many
other things could mimic the planet so
I'm going to show you some real transit
we call them transit light curves and
here you can see the this is just time
in hours and these are all giant planets
the transit lasts for a few hours this
is a few hours in here and it's also
showing you the size of the planet
compared to the size of the star and
where the planet is crossing on the star
and actually you can see they're all
different sometimes people would call
this like a family portrait and they're
all look a little different they're
different sizes compared to the star
they transit a different part and so now
I just have to show a few more technical
slides because I was thinking some of
you do know about exoplanets and some of
you may have heard in the news about two
weeks ago there's a planet called kepler
452b and so yeah some of you have read
about that so it's just gonna shed a
little light on it first that's the
artist conception which you would have
seen in the news and I wanted to show
you what the real data looks like and
here is kepler 452b this is a so if you
don't understand the next two slides you
don't have to understand the rest you
don't have to understand them to
understand the rest of the talk but I
just wanted to give you something to
chew on so this is days actually and
this is like 200 days 400 days out to
1,400 days this is a few years of data
Kepler space telescope looked at that
one patch of sky for four years and all
of these are points of data taken by the
telescope and so remember we're looking
for a star that's constant brightness
and time and looking for a tiny little
drop that signifies a planet now I don't
know if any of you can see that drop on
here first of all you note these gaps
are it's when the spacecraft wasn't
taking data sometimes it had a problem
and went into safe mode where it didn't
do anything
other times when it was down linking
data to earth kepler couldn't take data
it actually had to rotate four times a
year so the solar panels would be
pointing the right way
actually no what's really funny is they
gave you a little signal here the
triangles are you can't see it actually
you can't see it in the data and indeed
computers would search for it we
wouldn't do this by eye although
initially people looked at the data by
eye and when computer finds a signal a
drop in brightness it will bend the data
together it will take all that data and
fold it onto the same period and phase
and here's what the transit light curve
looks like so this is what it looks like
the detection went from the space
telescope taking data for four years
using computer algorithms to search for
these little tiny drops in brightness
and putting the data all together to get
this little tiny drop in brightness and
this here is several hours and this
little drop here looks like it's just
about let's say a hundred parts per
million but in my one more technical
slide this planet was claimed to be the
most earth-like ever planet ever found
that meant it's about about the size of
Earth a little bigger and it's receiving
about the same amount of energy from its
star so just for those of you this is my
last kind of technical slide this is
planet size compared to earth size and
this is the amount of at the bottom it's
showing you the amount of energy
compared to our Sun so earth would be
down here right at the bottom of the
graph at one earth size and this other
planet we don't know it's this is what I
wanted to convey to you we do not know
the planets exact size we do not know
exactly how much energy from the star is
hitting the planet
all we know is that the planet could be
any size and any amount of energy from
the star hitting the planet in this box
here in this oval rather and so here's
where the habitable zone is for this
particular planet so if the planets if
we could make a better measurement and
found that the planet was here it would
be way too big and way too hot to be
habitable so this was just a more
complicated way of saying we don't know
everything about the planet actually we
only know the size and and approximate
we know the size with some uncertainty
and we know about how much energy is
hitting from from the star hitting the
planet top of its atmosphere also with
some uncertainty so what we'd like to do
is find planets around stars that we can
study in more detail
and what we're gonna do next is in the
search for other Earth's we're looking
for transiting planets and I want you to
know that there are stars actually of
all different sizes there are these
giant stars really huge the yellow one
is like our Sun it's just a cartoon
diagram to show you all these different
stars sizes to scale there's this red
giant with such a hugely evolved star
and now look at this little planet I
stuck on here this is about the size of
Earth this would be the size of our Sun
I now look at this red dwarf star a
small star very common type of star in
our galaxy and look at that planet do
you think that planets the same size you
know it is the same size cuz I just cut
and paste but it looks so much bigger
here look how much bigger it looks I'm
just trying to show you that actually
that planet is blocking out so much more
of the star the small star compared to
the Sun and so actually what we're gonna
do in the search for another earth is we
actually will combine the most favorable
planet finding technique transits for
the smallest planets and the most
favorable star type so that's our way to
go forward actually it's to look for a
big earth or an earth-sized planet
transiting a small star so in this case
we're not going to find like a true
earth twin it's more like an earth
cousin but let me actually describe it a
little more by taking you on a virtual
trip to this small planet translating a
small star first of all that small star
has a much lower luminosity output than
our Sun and imagine for a moment like
standing near a fire if the fire is
really small you have to get closer to
it for the same amount of warmth
compared to a bigger fire so for these
small planets orbiting small stars the
habitable zone is much closer to the
star and so in this case if we were to
be able to visit this planet actually
the Sun would be very big in the sky
huge like this and this artist's who
made this image also is showing you
other planets in the same system and the
artists also use the artist's license to
make it a red sky with purple clouds
now on this planet believe it or not
that the planets that are close to the
star because of tidal forces from the
star it turns out we believe that most
of these planets would show the same
face to the star at all times just like
the moon shows the same face to earth so
that means that every time it rotates
once it goes around the star once so one
year is equal to one day actually but
what this would mean for us if we were
visiting the planet is that the star or
the Sun would always be in the same
place in the sky at all times so you
could choose to vacation where it's
always daytime and sunny or you could
choose for the astronomers you would
choose to go where it's always dark but
actually you might want to go where the
Sun is always setting because that would
be permanent um now if you're on this
planet for any children who might be in
the audience the good thing about this
is the year is so short because the
planet is close to the star and because
of Kepler's law a closer planet orbits
more quickly depending on the mass of
the star and so in this particular
example I chose that planet would be
orbiting the star about every 20 days so
you'd have your birthday every 20 days
but that wouldn't be so great for the
parents okay now if we were to be able
to visit the so-called small planet
transiting the small star it actually
may not be so great after all because
these red dwarf stars tend to have a lot
of flares they're very active they have
a lot of activity and that means that if
you're using your phone or any
electronics it may get knocked out and
it wouldn't be so great maybe for us if
we could visit because all those UV rays
coming from these M stars are very
active would be very bad for our health
so we'd probably have to go go to the
dark side and I want you to know that
over the years a lot of scientists go
back and forth they've complained about
these planets well if it's tightly
locked one side is getting heated the
other side is cold this could be a real
problem for the atmosphere it wouldn't
be though the atmosphere would circulate
the energy or they'd say well it's so
close to the star it might not be able
to get water delivered to it from
asteroids we're not worried about that
and the reason is because it's really
just a great shortcut a shortcut to
earth 2.0 is finding a super earth like
a big earth transiting a small star and
how will we find another earth just
some rice will use transits it's the
most favorable planet-finding technique
will search small stars with the
habitable zones close to the star and
will consider super Earths so actually I
just want to share with you something
you may not know about
it's called transiting exoplanet survey
telescope or tests and test is an MIT
led NASA mission it's gonna launch in
2017 and it builds upon the Kepler the
pioneering Kepler space telescope and
tests actually what it's going to do
actually is find you know it should find
a few more thousand planets actually but
number is we're not really necessarily
interested in quantity we want quality
and we want to find those small planets
transiting those small stars so that we
can look at their atmospheres later and
we'll do that with another telescope
called the James Webb Space Telescope so
I just have a couple pictures about
tests it's actually one of my main jobs
now is to work on the test Science
Center and here's actually a model of
tests it's actually not that big right
it's about about a big like industrial
washing machine here's the pIJ or
Drecker that's myself here's another
physics professor here's the deputy pi
roland van der speck and this here you
can see the antenna this is just a
spacecraft bus but inside that bus
actually are four basically identical
cameras think of this like a glorified
telephoto lens and to show you a picture
of the lens this you put your smallest
person in the photograph so that the
lens looks really big um
actually what it is is a giant baffle
and this camera here it's just a lens
with a special CCD detector and this was
one of the examples we had to build a
prototype and test it shake it like to
see if it would withstand the launch the
vibrations from launch and he did
thermal cycle it he didn't cool it and
he didn't cool it to see if it could
survive and this was actually at NASA
headquarters a few years ago when we had
our final presentation for which we won
the competition to get selected okay so
see what else I can tell you about this
it's about a hundred millimeter
effective pupil diameter and the
bandpass would be all visible
wavelengths actually it's a special
camera though you wouldn't like just get
this at the store it's specially
designed to be
a thermal and not to have any I mean you
probably don't notice this if you
remember your camera like from let's say
the old days it could have vignetting or
like weird behavior at the edges this is
made to not have that actually because
we want to get as much great quality
data as we can so how and when will we
find earth 2.0 well we really think we
have a plan for it it's the whole
community NASA will launch a telescope
in 2017 it's an all Sky Survey for these
big Earth's transiting small stars
if this earth exists out there around a
small star we have the capability to
find it and identify it by the 2020s and
in a moment I'm going to come back and
tell you a bit more about atmospheres
and other things about planets but I
wanted to next get to this kind of
follow-on question well if we do find a
planet and look at its atmosphere and
see that it looks interesting can we go
there okay so to talk about that it's
worthwhile to think about distances in
our solar system and beyond and here's a
real photograph of our Sun how big do
you think earth would be compared to
this image this actually is a sunspot
and it's about the size of Earth I
actually had to search to find the right
photo but this one does the job the next
question is if this is imagine the Sun
is the size and the earth is that that
size where would you think earth would
be physically speaking if we were to
make a model of our Earth's Sun distance
to scale why don't you raise your hand
if you think you're where maybe where
the earth would be it's a bit of a trick
question okay well it turns out that
Earth actually is about a hundred Sun
diameters away from the Sun so if you
just think of this that was just a lucky
coincidence actually but if we just
imagine a hundred Suns now I think it
would be outside of this room probably
out on the street somewhere maybe a
couple blocks away so that's how far
earth would be from the Sun now for a
moment we have to I want you to imagine
if this is our Sun and that's to scale
where would the next star be this one
actually have to calculate because they
didn't realize the Sun was gonna be this
big on the screen so I should probably
answer that one myself I would have to
guess it would be about mmm let's see
sometimes I forget what city I'm in you
know cuz I travel so much now that's not
true let me think for a second I think
I'd have to put this somewhere in Russia
Russia's big enough to give me an area
of uncertainty he didn't far far far
okay so the point is that stars are very
far apart you know most of space is
empty actually and Alpha Centauri our
nearest star system is 4.22 light-years
away so actually it's far and Voyager
one would take over seventy thousand
years to reach the nearest star if it
was pointed in the right direction so
that's a really long time but I've seen
that this is just thinking how to phrase
the next part where you know used to
have this huge giggle factor someday
let's try to go to a nearby star but you
know what actually that is slowly going
away actually and even just this
afternoon I met with some colleagues and
people are really getting ready for this
you know we wanted to look for planets
around Alpha Centauri if there's a
planet there we believe someone will
figure out how to get there and that
will be longer than a hundred years that
it's going to take to build the clock
but I think it's gonna happen actually
and I don't know how I don't know
exactly how I just know that it's the
drive to go there is so strong and in
fact some people think engineers that
are alive now on this planet that we
could find a way to go let's need a
tenth the speed of light that that is
kind of within reach at some point and
let's imagine for a moment that that's
the case let's see that would take about
oh if we could travel at the tenth the
speed of light it would take about forty
four zero years to get to the nearest
star
that doesn't include speeding up or
slowing down but nonetheless I was
wondering if there's anyone in this
audience think about how old you would
be forty years from now if you would
actually consider making the trip should
we say that we had a way to go there I
mean actually you know every single time
people would go another stuff to say
because I always forget to say well it
would be a one-way trip and would you
still go and yes actually everywhere
people have this desire to go so
although we can't go there now you know
I no longer say it'll never happen I
think sometime it will happen it will be
galvanized when we find a planet around
Alpha Centauri
so can we go there not for now okay if
we can't go there why look and now I get
to my part of my favorite part of the
talk I call it the real search for alien
life and this is what I work on this is
my main reason my favorite thing when I
get to work on on research and it's
about the search for gases in an
exoplanet atmosphere that might be
attributed to life but first science
fiction said we have to travel you know
these yeah it's so funny because in
science fiction they always said we had
to travel there like the enterprise
would have to travel at great distances
and incredible speeds to get an orbit
around an alien world so that Spock
could analyze the atmosphere as
habitable and if they were life-forms on
the planet and the thing is that you
know they never thought well why don't
we just build like a ginormous telescope
and look for far away and we don't know
actually if they did that or not but it
would have been a pretty boring show if
they just did that so you know we don't
have to figure out warp speed and I hate
to dissuade any of the junior engineers
but right now we do that actually we
take we observe planets from far away
and here's a real photograph of the
Hubble Space Telescope which we use and
we meaning the community uses and this
actually was a real photo taken by the
departing space shuttle Atlantis after
it did a final servicing mission to
Hubble and Hubble actually we use it to
study planet atmospheres and I just want
you to know that although we don't
observe small planet atmospheres yet we
do not see anything like an earth-sized
planet atmosphere we have studied a
giant planet atmospheres hot giant
planets they're the easiest atmospheres
to study they're big hot atmospheres
they have water vapour and other things
in it that makes it easy and so I'm just
gonna spend a few minutes telling you
about how what we're looking for and why
and how it all works so you can have
something to take away well here's a
picture of a picture of a rainbow and I
hope everyone here has got to see
rainbow at some point but in this
rainbow what you probably haven't seen
them because if you look at the rainbow
in a lot of detail you know you could
actually see that some colors are
missing some parts of these colors are
actually missing and if we actually take
the sun's light and spread it out not by
refraction and a rain
drop by a special instrument called a
spectrograph we actually see this and
here you see little tiny parts are
missing actually and these are due to
absorption either in the sun's
atmosphere or the Earth's atmosphere or
both and I want you to see here there's
very different lines missing and see
this is a really big one there's some
very thin ones and they're all over the
place actually and each atom and
molecule has a special set of lines that
it absorbs and these missing colors its
absorption by gases in the atmosphere
and it's been studied for many decades
we're still studying it now actually and
you can either measure it in the lab or
other people can do very complicated
computer quantum mechanical calculations
because each molecule has a specific
fingerprint in each atom and you can
actually work out what all these these
lines are actually it's there are a few
things we don't know and actually it's
just reading today on their way over on
the plane there are these things called
the diffused interstellar bands that
even in between stars there's the tiny
tiny bit of gas and there's some things
we don't know what they are actually and
they'd finally identified these bands do
you do like a buckyball a giant form of
carbon so anyway this is the atmosphere
and I wanted you to know that the so we
call this spectra are required to
identify as planet as earth-like because
earth and Venus are about the same size
and about the same mass and they fall in
that member that uncertain habitable
zone I showed you the graph we don't
totally know where if like kepler 452b
we're not so sure of all the parameters
so earth and venus would basically be
identical to any planet search technique
today and unless we can get a spectrum
and identify the gases in the atmosphere
we we need to be able to move forward by
looking for gases in the planet
atmosphere I just have to pause for a
second and ask if anyone was keeping
track of time I'm Stewart were you
keeping track of the time because I
didn't notice what time we started so
okay so alright so the question is what
gases should we be looking for in
another planet and here we have on our
own earth we have studied it literally
in every type of detail you could
imagine on our own planet Earth
oxygen is our
bio signature gas we think that on our
planet well we know in our planet that
oxygen fills our atmosphere to 20
percent by volume and you know without
life without photosynthetic plants and
photosynthetic bacteria there would be
virtually no oxygen and so oxygen is
filling our atmosphere to 20 percent by
volume and that is what we call our most
robust bio signature gas because it's
such a highly reactive gas it shouldn't
actually last in our atmosphere at all
really it should be it shouldn't be
there actually and we have other gases
too we like like methane nitrous oxide
we actually have a whole list of gases
here we have things like called dimethyl
sulfide methyl chloride we're kind of
slowly working our way through trying
literally to exhaust every possible
molecule that might be produced by life
it turns out that even like when you
walk through the pine forest and those
chemicals coming off of trees that makes
it smell so nice those technically are
bio signatures they're just produced in
such tiny quantities that you know we
can't see them from far away so there's
this huge kind of branch of research
that's just starting to flourish now
about what types of gases should we be
looking for in planets far away and we
can come back to that in the qat if you
have more specific questions about that
so if we can't go there why look we call
it remote sensing to search for gases in
a planet atmosphere that might be
attributed to life and this is actually
a really really hard problem because
although we've observed several
exoplanet atmospheres already giant
planets we mostly understand what we're
seeing this whole thing about finding
life is a real challenge and we've made
it all sound so easy up till now if
you've ever heard about this or just
looking for gas as far away oxygen is so
great but actually almost any other gas
other than oxygen we have to assess
whether it is present in levels so far
out of equilibrium that it shouldn't be
there and then we have to try to rule
out every single possibility before we
can even say it might be made by life
but the problem we're facing is that
unlike that earlier example we don't
really know what the equilibrium state
is when you say we want to find a gas
that is so far out of equilibrium
because planets are complicated gases
are coming out of the surface the star
has ultraviolet radiation the same thing
that creates smog in our cities it's
also creating chemicals and so we're
really trying to work out
every last possibility we're working
hard on it now so for the last part of
my talk I actually have to tell you
about something that is really probably
one of the more exciting things going on
right now but I have to let you know
that transits are only the first part of
a long story because these transits when
the planet goes in front of the star and
the star light drops in that tiny amount
it's only possible for very perfectly
aligned planetary systems okay we think
that all planets all stars are born in a
random way that means that their
rotation access could be in any
direction it's just a random part of how
the ball of gas that collapses to form a
star actually ends up being and it just
means that the planet's orbit could be
like this or like this or anyway it
won't necessarily transit and in fact
for an earth the chance to transit for
an Earth and earth earth earth systems
from our Sun around another sun-like
star is just one part in 200 and so if
we want to find the nearby earths the
ones someday we might go to the ones
that will be bright enough for us to
study their atmospheres we actually have
to do a whole different technique and
that comes back to that Firefly analogy
where the star is so bright that the
glare is bleeding all over the detector
we need to find a way to block out the
Starlight so we can see the planets
directly and here there were
conveniently three planets so we call
that direct imaging where we will block
out the Starlight and see the planet
directly now there's a main challenge
here in in blocking out starlight and
that has to do with the laws of physics
called diffraction and here I'm showing
you a circle imagine that your telescope
mirror is this actually imagine that
we're blocking out the Starlight by like
a giant screen in space that's a perfect
circle you'd think we would just block
out the Starlight perfectly but that's
not what would happen actually we would
see this ringing pattern called Airy
rings and this analogy I want you to
think about light being like a wave
where if you drop a pebble in a pond you
would see ripples it's a similar kind of
thing so look at this if you drop a
pebble in a pond you'll see ripples if
we block out the Starlight with a giant
circular screen we will also see ripples
because the light is diffracting around
the edges now for imagine imagine for a
moment we put a giant screen in space
that's a very special shape like this
the star shape
then we would actually get this image
here this would be like dropping a
pebble in a pond when instead of having
ripples the area around the pebble is so
perfectly smooth to one part in ten
billion and that all the ripples are
pushed out to the edges and that's what
we actually want to do we want to put a
giant screen in space and that's a very
special shape but before I continue
because the people who there are many
ways to do to suppress starlight we call
it blocking out starlight you actually
could put this very special shape inside
the telescope also that's a whole
different story so I'm going to talk to
you now about the star shade and this
animation shows you a star shade and
telescope launching together were the
petals unfurl from their stowed position
and a central truss would expand with
those petals snapping into place now
they have to be very precisely made so
that the shape of the star shade and the
flatness of it and just how it stays
together is a challenge and the star
shade actually would have to fly very
far from the telescope tens of thousands
of kilometers to block out that
starlight just perfectly so we can find
planets around it it's called the star
shade and we actually the soonest the
star shade actually is going strong and
actually tomorrow I'll be going to San
Diego to an optical engineering meeting
where I'll be talking there about the
star shade but just so you know that
it's a real thing that with real
hardware I want you to see this
animation this is from August 2013 of
four of the petals and these petals were
stowed and now they're unfurling from
their stowed position these are larger
ons that actually snap into place
rigid izing the pedal there's only four
because that's all they could afford to
do it's mostly the place where they
attach that and it's the real thing
they're checking actually know what
they're checking is to make sure that
those petals can deploy to position with
respect to each other of millimeters and
that they can do that over and over
again no matter how many times it's
deployed now you're seeing that second
stage of deployment I always get asked
why are there people in this movie but
here the point was to
show that not that it could deploy
automatically and by the way later
versions do deploy automatically but
that there are the people but that the
pedals deploy relative to each other in
the same way each time now what I want
you to know about this central truss is
it was not built just for the starshade
actually this is left over from
constructing large radio deployables
that have gone to space big things that
are that the big inner disk is 15 meters
even 20 meters in diameter and the star
shade we want to build would be about 15
or 20 meters in diameter and later
generations of this actually have
smaller trusses that are more suitable
for the star shade so the heritage from
these comes from large things in space
the pedals and how they still and deploy
are what is new here's a myself and two
of my team members Maggie Turnbull and
Acura barish and here we're holding this
giant pedal it has this long tip here if
it looks dangerous that's because it is
and it's a very special shape this
particular pedal was made to demonstrate
that that pedal could be made precisely
to about a hundred and fifty microns so
there's this real hardware development
going on in the lab this is a pedal
prototype it says use for manufacturing
tolerance verification tests so if we
can't go there no I really submit I
really lost track of that if we can't go
there why look we wanted to remote
sensing we have big plans to build
complicated space telescopes the
starshade that would fly tens of
thousands of kilometers from the
telescope using let's say a two meter
telescope is probably is most likely to
be our very best option to find the true
Earth's so to close I just want to leave
you with a thought it's amazing to me
that I've been working on exoplanets for
twenty years when I first started
working on exoplanets people didn't even
exist they were didn't even believe that
exoplanets existed even the professors
at my own University where I was in grad
school and the reason was because there
were only a few and they were very close
to the star and people didn't believe it
because we thought that planets should
be far from the star like Jupiter is and
these big planets were found and people
just thought the star was pulsating or
there was something else going on and
over the years people started believing
it some people
getting excited about it but most people
had never heard of it
you know you'd sort of meet someone on
the airplane what do you work on well I
work on the on exoplanets oh what's that
and now it's like oh yeah I mean of
course they know of course they heard
about it you know in the New York Times
or they read about it and so you get to
this point where it's incredible but
even now all of my students they of
course they're exoplanets for children
of course there are planets in the
habitable zone actually they learn that
from that eyes on exoplanets thing
because they click and they can put
habitable zones and so it's incredible
now and so what my goal is and my my
peers is we want to take that one next
step actually and we want to be able to
take our children and grandchildren
nieces and nephews to a dark site and to
point to a sun-like star and to say that
star has a planet like Earth thank you
okay thanks sounds like what you mean by
like earth means alive like Earth is
that correct well like Kurtis has a lot
of different meanings what I personally
mean is in Earth around a Sun and a
planet that has oceans and continents
and lush vegetation will you be able to
detect atmospherically things like
tectonic action and stuff okay that's a
really hard question the funny thing was
before we were saying someone suggested
that our question to seduce a really
hard ones
okay plate tectonics is his problem we
likely will not be able to detect any
signs of plate tectonics or any gases of
activity for sure right mmm I mean
possibly okay for my any asks what do
you think of the Drake Equation these
days given what we're discovering okay
and probably need to explain with the
Drake Equation right well the Drake
Equation was written by Frank Drake many
decades ago and he used it as a tool to
illustrate what are the chances for
intelligent life out there and they're
about six terms in the Drake Equation
the first few are like how many stars
form each year in the Milky Way and it
kind of moves on to how long do you
think an intelligent civilization could
last and the Drake Equation is still
useful but actually myself and others
have reinvented the Drake Equation and
we use it for our own purposes to say
well what are the chances we're gonna
find signs of life by way of gases in
the planet atmosphere but just like the
Drake Equation
we can only really measure the first few
terms the rest are very speculative and
so we can always kind of tweak them in a
favorable direction but we give
ourselves about a 50/50 chance I'd say
add your new equation to the
presentation because that equation
presumably will keep evolving until it's
predictive and very nice be seeing how
the terms right we find signs of if and
when we find signs of life we could work
back yes
Tim raised asked how his Earth's bio
signature fared over the billions of
years they've been periods perhaps long
ones when we would have looked pretty
dead yes good question so oxygen for
many for billions of years there was no
sign of out there was no oxygen on our
in our atmosphere or initially when
oxygen was produced it reacted with
rocks and it didn't accumulate in the
atmosphere so for a long time yes our
planet actually would have looked dead
even when it had life well now there was
a long period of microbial life that was
not putting a lot of oxygen in the
atmosphere right and that would have
been undetectable things we don't know
right now some people think that we had
a period of time when we had methanogens
methane producing bacteria and a huge
amount of them and they would have
produced methane that would have
definitely been a bio signature if there
was a huge amount of it but we don't
know if our earth had that are there not
planets in our own system that have a
lot of methane that's presumably not
biome genic yes so we have to get into a
little more detail now but some planets
okay let's put it like Jupiter itself
has a lot of methane and any big planet
that can hold on to hydrogen should have
methane on it actually but a planet like
Earth that is so it's gravity is
relatively weak actually it's like when
you're walking around with the heel I'm
sure that's happened to almost everyone
here but if you have the helium balloon
and you were a child and you actually
like let it go and it floated away light
gases like hydrogen and helium they're
not trapped here in our atmosphere but
on planets where they do have hydrogen
trapped if they're massive planets or
cold planets then they should also have
methane so we think we can sort through
all the possibilities if we were to see
a lot of methane that we could work
through the options so you said there's
research jamming ahead on looking for
other bye or signature gases does this
involve theorizing biology different
than what we know so far that's a tough
question and right now it does not
unfortunately I know there's a lot of
fans of like silicon-based life and
other things
but the reality is for astronomers you
know we can only see what life does life
generates gases it makes byproducts we
can't see what the life is actually and
there may be a future where we can put
all that together but right now we're
really just still struggling as to what
we're even looking for so it's
interesting you said that you're when
you're when you finally able to get a
spectrographic analysis of a an actual
individual star figuring out whether
that represents equilibrium is itself an
issue for that I hadn't realized because
you know Jim Lovelock figured out that
Mars was in some kind of vehicle there
briam therefore did but he was I guess
knowing more than you guys know about
exoplanets he was knowing more yeah
Kevin Kelly yes what's the future of
computational optical very large
telescopes you know beyond phaser a and
various things how our telescopes on
some kind of Moore's Law curve of
getting an insanely better every period
of time well they're getting bigger and
more expensive let me think I gotta
think about how to answer that one I'm
not totally sure what his question is
specifically but you know we have this
very right now the biggest telescope so
don't say eight meters in diameter or
ten meters in diameter optical
telescopes on the ground and we actually
think we've maxed out on the size we can
make a monolithic mirror so the next
generation telescopes they're 20 meters
in diameter or 40 meters in diameter and
they're composed of segments that are
faced together some of them have small
segments some have big segments that
themselves are eight meters and so in
that case you know these next telescopes
it takes longer to make like the next
step up and it's just harder actually
and so it's not clear if beyond the next
generation you can still keep making
segmented mirrors and telescopes we may
have to think of some whole new way to
operate what's gonna cost for the
starshade equip telesco okay I know
you're gonna laugh because I'm going to
give you a very specific
number I get asking it because maybe
somebody has it okay all right all right
so if we just wanted to do the star
shade itself that is I showed you just
very briefly that we do have real
hardware we're really pushing to working
all the technology that itself would be
including launch it would be about 650
million and that includes reserves of
about 30% now that doesn't include the
telescope but the good news is we're
hoping that every telescope that is
launched to space will be what we call
star shade ready ready to work with the
star shade so it would have a camera
that could see the star shade the LED
bank and the laser and and guide on it
properly in the right kind of instrument
to study the planet atmosphere once that
goes and also have to have a radio
communication to be able to communicate
with the star shade to formation fly and
there's the telescope being launched in
2024 called w first it's a two point
four meter mirror same size as Hubble
and that whole thing we hope is going to
go far away from Earth's gravity where
we can do formation of line so our plan
right now is to get the star shade ready
push it forward so that it we have a
hope of actually going with w first say
more about formation flying obviously
you've got telescope and the star she a
their calamity
I said tens of thousands of kilometers
and thousands of kilometers apart and
we're talking about micron precision in
the petals so this is manufacturing the
petals well it's actually a 100 micron
so that's a lot better than one micron
but yes but well I can actually explain
I can tell you about the formation of
lineup but it's kind of cool actually so
what's gonna happen at first I'll tell
you how it will work and then I'll tell
you the part that's really hard so
essentially when you have this star
shade and telescope every time it moves
to a new star it has to realign so it'll
take like a week or so for that star
shade or telescope to fly across the sky
and line up and first of all we know
where this the star shaving telescope
are because they're radio communicating
to earth we can see the background stars
where the star shade is the telescope
can so that's how it knows where it is
and then actually when it gets closer
and closer to the star the telescope
will see like a big LED Bank on the star
shade no
that is and as it's getting closer to
the star a laser actually will be used
to line it up precisely and what's the
best the most clever thing that the
engineers came up with is that once it's
aligned properly you know how it stays
aligned because some of that diffracted
light at much longer wavelengths than
are being used to study the planet is
actually itself fused now when we think
of formation flying we have had
experience formation flying in Earth's
gravity docking at the space station
there's been a mission that went to the
moon it was a four-month long mission
called Grail and what it did was it did
laser ranging so they weren't tightly
formation flying but two spacecraft
orbited the moon and they sent a laser
back and forth and they could tell if
they were closer or further it told them
the precise gravity of the moon and so
when we look at all these different
situations in thinking that the star
shade will be far away from Earth's
gravity in a benign disturbance
environment we're mostly left with what
we call a sensing problem that is can
you see that laser line that led Bank
far away precisely enough to know
exactly where it is to formation fly so
the story is we do have heritage we've
boiled it down to one specific thing
that we're going to be working on did I
convince you yes so the so the star seed
is its own little spaceship that has
capability of maneuvering and travelling
some distance not enough I guess your
are there herbal issues is it so far
that that's not a big deal or is it
having to deal with earth in the rest of
the solar system well we want to get it
far from Earth
so we could either be in what we call a
heliocentric earth trail earth lady in
orbit or earth trail in orbit or far
away at the so called Earth Sun LaGrant
so has to be very far from Earth far
from the gravity discovers they're now
at one of them Al Gore camera is right
which one I'll to the other side okay
which is significantly farther I forget
well it just depends
you want to be in the earth and sun but
we don't want to be seen like the sunlit
part of Earth or having the Sun in the
wrong location okay back to you a nice
money question bill nigut
yes what area of research work most
effectively increased our capabilities
search for earth-like and I'll say
lifelike exoplanets in the next 10 - a
large number of years if funding were
not a limiting factor okay well if it's
not limited at all then okay so I have
to confess that with the whole tests and
James Webb setup and even with this
first the star shade is the first
generation you know we still have to get
really really lucky because anything we
can conceive of now even the large 30
meter ground-based telescopes
you only have a good shot at finding
another earth but they may just find one
you know or two and we think about our
own earth there was this good question
about well our earth wasn't oxygenated
its whole life it looked at in the past
or maybe we'll find a Venus instead of
an earth we'd really really like in the
future for someone to be able to launch
a telescope that's so big and capable
that it could literally find dozens of
earths you know not just one or two that
we're struggling and hoping to get in
our you know next 10 or 20 years and so
that would be very expensive very
complicated
we're like a ten billion dollar type of
mission starshade all budgeted and paid
for and coming you know the stars eat is
not all budgeted not all paid for okay
so so anything that's so new and on it
and forefront you actually have to
finish convincing yourself you know the
rest of the world that you can actually
do it and we have actually five specific
problems we're working on one is the
sensing problem we think they're all
solvable one of them believe it or not
is that that star shade if the edges the
edges of those petals they have to be as
sharp as a razor if they're not actually
sunlight will will you know Bend around
them and scatter off those edges
actually and get into the image because
remember we're trying to block out the
Starlight to one
are in 10 billion so even things like
our own Sun or anything coming by maybe
even Venus or something very bright so
figuring that out so we have the sort of
list of things and first we'd like to
knock all those things sound and that's
about a twenty million dollar price tag
on that and then to get it fully ready
so that we've tested everything we can
think of and we've demoed it all and
we've done also ongoing or sub scale
tests like the small star shades in the
lab to show that you can really block
the star light out like you expect it to
getting it that far is more like 150
million and then the rest of the costs
is just for building the spacecraft and
the launch and things that people know
how to do already okay so somebody who
says okay I want I wanted to discover if
there's life of the sequence of events
is 20 million 150 million and then what
for the we're like four hundred million
for the wrestler blinders hey this is
like the biggest cosmic question we got
yeah the answer of or absolutely alone
sorry folks be very careful would be
huge the answer of there's other life or
even lots of other life changes
everything so when we say key concern
570 million there's just do it yo
there's I just finished reading the
Martian I'm gonna see the movie with
Matt Damon when it comes out shortly
interstellar was wonderful gravity was
wonderful interest in serious engaging
of space is with us still even though
we're supposed to have lost interest
what happened I say Italy I got
distracted because I was reading this
question I was thinking that answered
well combine like that one I like that
question so your question was interest
is still there so maybe it's just
because Hollywood loves to try to
simulate zero-g but something keeps
people excited about prospects of space
you know the Star Trek it's a long time
ago though I'm not the round of that
coming along and these realistic space
exploration by humans films keep coming
along and so I would have to say NASA's
funding is not keeping up with the
public interest well I think there's a
few things going on one is that I really
do believe we are born explorers and
maybe it was so in the past when people
were you know sport Antarctica for the
first time and everything we don't have
that now we think of our oceans are not
fully explored but arguably all of land
is and I feel like space is really the
place where we can still dream of
exploring it's still where things are
unknown and so that's a big thing but
also you know I think in terms of the
NASA and funding I mean one point is
that things are just you know you pick
the low-hanging fruit you do the easy
things you have your backyard telescope
but eventually you know you're going for
the 30 meter telescope the big
telescopes in space things the harder
things are just more expensive is there
low-hanging fruit with your search and
high hanging fruit that I mean what's
the difference well oh hang what can you
get in the next few years and what will
it take a lot longer to get okay
well I'd say in the next few years the
test spacecraft will launch the one with
the four cameras and we'll find the pool
of rocky planets that we will follow up
to look at their atmospheres with the
James Webb Space Telescope
that's a telescope launched in 2018 you
know if we're lucky we may find
something but the chance of us really
finding science of life is small on that
one we hope to launch the star shade
without one we can find a few earths and
look at their spectra for life so in the
next 10 or 20 years that's what we have
to look forward to you probably won't be
surprised by a question probably often
get is there any science fiction or
reading in your personal background
let's see
No well so what I would have to admit
that my favorite science fiction author
although this was really more from about
20 years ago was Robert Heinlein and I
read all of his books
many years after so they weren't totally
contemporary because when he had written
them you know he predicted many things
like the ATM and other things like
personal robots are only now just maybe
coming but I just loved reading those
and I read like everyone I love time
travel books recently I started to read
a new generation or let's say genre of
science fiction including the Martian
and other sort of more realistic things
about going to Mars but I'd have to say
it was really mostly just Heinlein a
little bit about the students you're
getting these days do you deal with
students are you dealing strictly with
the research scenes okay well there's
sort of two different types of students
now and unfortunately one of them I
really hate to say anything negative but
unfortunately that's the first thing
that comes to mind but I think it just
speaks to anyone who is a parent or you
know will be or it's a grandparent or an
uncle or an aunt but there's a sort of
sense of entitlement that I see amongst
of my students which is not it's not
helpful people who are yeah and I
actually don't know what to do about it
so I I'm still sort of sorting through
the edelman yes because I think it's it
must have come from like when everyone
gets praised when they don't deserve it
or you know there's like no sense of
like I don't they just expect that they
deserve everything and it just it's not
a good way to kind of go through through
life actually so there's sort of that
sad but there's the other set who just
stick with that for me how do you fix it
how do you fix there you've got a
student figures like they're already
halfway there what do you do I don't
know how to fix that part I don't know
if that problems fixable I'll take that
student well sometimes you don't find
this stuff out until you know time goes
by actually so I've had to regroup and
think through it a little a little more
now okay moving from unfortunately to
fortunately what you know the fortunate
students are just tremendously
incredible and we had a great summer
with the set I hope they're watching
this but I had a set of summer students
and it's part of a project where
well we wanted to try to understand what
kinds of gases could be bio signatures
but given that life on Earth literally
have produces thousands of maybe let's
say a thousands thousands of gases how
would you go about this well some other
colleagues and I had made a long list of
what we thought was all molecules that
could be in gas form and so what I had
the students do was see are their
spectra for these molecules and we would
get together and work and they're just
so hard-working and they have a great
sense of humor and we just wrote a lot
of code and searched through like online
databases and one of the students made a
GUI like a nice user interface we can
look at all the spectra and compare them
and so some students are just so like
thirsty to work on a problem and the
ones who are really end up being suited
for science I mean unfortunately that
image of you know the MIT student and
professor just always working and always
tech coding it's it's true in a lot of
cases but it's that same desire when you
get stuck on a problem it's almost like
reading a mystery novel and you know you
can't put it down because you have to
get to the end it's like that and so the
best students are ones where we're on
the same wavelength
you know we're in sync and we have a
problem that we love working on and that
we can work on together that's the best
case are the spectral lines to a cold
front offer lines they aren't really
called Fraunhofer lines and I believe
that specifically refers to a set of
lines in the sun's photosphere that were
discovered by Fraunhofer I once handled
the original slides that found hard from
a long glass slides I broke several of
them by accident
that's my contribution to astronaut back
to students jr. asked how would you
advise curious students to prepare for a
career in XO planetary science okay well
one thing is it seems like we can't get
away from computers and programming and
I'd say programming now isn't always
what it used to be because before we
honestly coded every single thing from
scratch and we sometimes we had like a
library of functions we could draw on
but now it's really oh it's really um I
was gonna say something funny but just
in case one of the students was watching
it I didn't I didn't want to say it but
now we really love using really well we
really love using Python I don't know if
anyone here yeah right because what
happens is before we had MIT was really
big on MATLAB and other things because
they provide a life you know there's
like a license for students and the sort
of secret is they also have a help desk
so if the student got stuck most of them
don't know this so you could actually no
email MATLAB and they would help you out
but the problem is you can't get inside
of it and it can be very slow and it's
not flexible but now with Python
everybody's writing their own i'm code
that you can download it's often very
hard to install because you have
libraries and problems with like what
your computer has versus what they're
they think you have but the downside of
that so the great side is there's a huge
power in it because anything that you
want or some complicated code that would
take you let's say six months to write
it's already there the downside is it
breeds a mentality where you really just
write like what we call a giant wrapper
and you just use things without thinking
and so I've seen a lot of a lot of that
also but you knowing how to use code and
to write code and not just to use things
as what we call black boxes I mean that
may be sound a little strange of
something to suggest but I think really
that's your main thing to the main tool
for so many disciplines today there's
lots of people are coming with code
training so does that yeah I already
covers that part of chemistry is trying
to meet many things like that
I'd say physics mostly I mean astronomy
is really applied physics it's great to
maintain interest but really just trying
to understand the nuts and bolts is
what's really important
very fiddler ask the question that you
noticed how does your work intersect
Lacetti that's at all right SETI search
for extraterrestrial intelligence
well SETI does intersect now because
SETI in addition to doing these surveys
of the sky and of stars everywhere
SETI can now actually focus in part on
stars with no planets it's like that
kepler-452b 6 and those systems now that
I would say is mostly how SETI
intersects and said you just got a bunch
of money that suggests that what you're
doing also should get that kind of money
yes well I do I don't answer no because
it just suggests this as you already
pointed out this you know increase in
interests in space and the fact that
these planets are out there people are
excited people want to accelerate our
opportunity to find signs of life
intelligent or otherwise so yeah and
elia what's the best neighborhood for
exoplanet she showed us that wonderful
image of where Kepler is looking at as a
rather small sample of a rather large
galaxy right well I think for now the
best neighborhood really are those stars
that are closest to our Sun and they're
still quite far away actually there's
about a hundred stars like our Sun
within about 30 light years but really
it's our solar neighborhood we want to
find things that are close because
they're bright and they're easier to
study and again because someday we hope
we might find a way to go there so
there's no particular preference of like
looking you know toward the center of
the galaxy you're away from the center
of the galaxy or anything like that I
mean not really for me personally but
the reason why Kepler Kepler heard a
very specific reason for being where it
is I mean towards the center of the
galaxy it's so densely populated with
stars it's very hard to see what's going
on and if you would look outside the
galaxy Kepler wouldn't have had enough
stars to find transits because remember
they have the planets have to be
specially aligned so you can each
different technique or each method has
its own special place in the galaxy
so Kevin Kelley is is there an emerging
sort of taxonomy as it's been quite
awhile now a taxonomy of stars and you
referred to it a lot is there a taxonomy
of planet
well when you ask that question it's
funny because we actually have you know
earth it's not too inventive right earth
super earth mini Neptune Neptune
you know Jupiter you know so actually no
actually and people fight actually about
what we should call things and everybody
uses different names but I think one
thing instead of the taxonomy yet is
what's going on and I'll just add it in
here but we are starting to think that
planets about 1.6 1.7 times the size of
Earth are smaller appeared to be
predominantly rocky and planets bigger
than about that appear to have like a
gas envelope and be of much lower
density than could be predominately
rocky have no life we assume we have no
life because we think that gas envelope
just isn't favorable for life yeah so
you got a theory of life that might
function on a gas planet I can't think
of really any great theory but Carl
Sagan himself wrote a paper actually
about Jupiter and the question is what's
really interesting actually better own
earth is that we have bacteria floating
around in our atmosphere on aerosols
little particles and so the thought was
well maybe in Jupiter you could have
little air cells and there's life
floating around and the reason we don't
like that theory is because Jupiter has
these giant convective cells and any
life if it's floating around it'll be
brought down to where it's actually
quite hot in Jupiter and so there's no
really theory for life on on a gas
planet a planet with a lot of gas yet in
this local solar system the only one we
know well the gas planet some of them
have pretty significantly interesting
satellites run their moons around them
that may be potential places for life is
that also an issue and exoplanets well
the issue is that the exoplanets I think
I explained we're so hard to find and
see
and so the moons are gonna be even more
hard right to find in C so we don't rule
them out for any really good reason only
because they're hard to see and any moon
without an atmosphere like your rope are
something that may have subsurface
oceans we can't see subsurface life in
any way so we expect them to be out
there in fact our the our moods of the
Gale so we're detecting gas planets were
even sort of getting imaging of them are
their moons potentially detectable
perhaps by their own transiting or
things like yes actually so
just FYI so exoplanets are often in the
news and we always say that exoplanets
have always delivered we've gotten
everything we wanted on our wish list
except for one thing and that is
exoplanet moons and everyone was hoping
that the Kepler data would show
exoplanet moons around giant planets
either by transit or other ways but we
haven't seen them but they'd have to be
big moons big like half the size of
Earth or bigger from a distance would we
detect the moon said that we have around
Saturn no problem none of our solar
system moons would be discoverable okay
so it's another couple levels of
resolution before you can get that so
you mentioned the newsworthy and
problematic issue there being more rocky
planets and fewer big-ass planets than
were expected by theory which is
fantastic
and so where are you and others going
with Theory given that little problem
we're mean others going so okay the you
know the theory was there to be lots of
gas lines knots many rocket planets and
then the reality is theirs doesn't match
that yeah
no I know you're a lot the funny thing
is is when I tell my students it's not
totally true now but when they do their
PhD defense and they get asked like
everything possible I say like look
every day is like a PhD defense because
they get asked all sorts of things even
things that I myself aren't working on
but what I think will end up that anyway
we can think of for why there are so
many of these small planets is probably
it's all of the above and so people
think of things like well perhaps some
of these planets have moved in close to
the star and have just lost their
atmosphere they were may be formed
bigger maybe like a Neptune and started
losing atmosphere because of solar wind
or being heated and that might account
for some of them but not all of them we
think the gas giants have a solid core
but we're not a hundred percent sure
including our including Jupiter were not
100 percent sure let me finish the the
and in other people think well perhaps
this is
when the planet forms like Jupiter we
think it formed and got big and it got
so massive that it sucked in everything
around it and it became dominant but
some people said well what about if seen
an inner planetary system lots of them
formed almost at the same time and no
one could dominate over the other well
they would all exhaust their feeding
zone and be dwarfed like they wouldn't
take over what the other one had because
they all kind of grew up together and
and so there's these variety of thinking
but it's not really clear yet which one
it will be she showed us one planet with
two suns and presumably a complicated
orbit it wasn't necessarily complex
really but the stars are orbiting each
other and the planet is orbiting the
outer and I like to say sunsets there
have got to be pretty exciting one of
the things Carl Sagan did and you got a
glimpse of it in this long short at the
beginning as he he described amazing
places that were you know already
identifiable I don't know of a planet
made of diamonds and you go out its
various things well I want to go there
the exoticness of the kinds of places
that are out there
seems to be intriguingly in one
increasing and increasingly ever more
detail is that what you're perceiving do
you mean out there for exoplanets or out
there anywhere exoplanets well yeah
let's hey sorry not just explodes
everywhere go on yeah well with
exoplanets it's really convoluted to
describe our models and how we you know
how we really interpret the data and see
things and so just describing what
they're like is a really kind of a tool
to communicate what we think it could be
but it's probably all of the above you
know we imagine that one planet could be
red red vegetation another one would
have green or some other color even the
variety frankly shocks me I mean this is
just sort of mechanics and chemistry not
even big life big life makes a lot of
variety that's evolution in Darwin that
big
on life it has much variety is pretty
strange and exciting in its own right so
whether or not there's things living
there once we become the things living
there these will be exotic places they
will but I also hope that all those
planets and all those orbits brings you
some you know or everyone some
reassurance because before you know
earth is definitely very special but I
think we have some sense now that it is
also somewhat random because we see all
these planets and all these different
orbits all different sizes and masses
and so earth happened to be just right
and surely there should be other planets
also out there that are also just right
different kinds of just right the do you
want to go any of these places or you
just wanted to find out if there's
something pulsing there for me I just
I'm not one of those people who would
volunteer to go to alpha cen so there's
a pulse of the places and this is part
of the SETI story is there a pull toward
other life it's most of it's not going
to be intelligent there's going to be
microbes and do we really want to go
visit microbes somewhere
the answer is yes probably because if
they can handle microbes that can handle
other things we might be interesting it
like if you come to microbial life to
microbial earth back when this was a
cool place to you start an oxygen regime
right yeah we've been cool but don't
forget back in the in the time of the
dinosaurs they couldn't have
communicated with us either they didn't
so you're right they didn't believe
their DNA we're discovering all they
left is a pattern of how their bones
looked so the lack of communication does
seem to be the norm but the lack of life
is not necessarily the norm it sounds
like and on that note what is clear from
what we've heard from Sara Seager
tonight is that there's a lot happening
in this century with this kind of
discovery and we're going to know a lot
more about life in the galaxy thanks to
you and the people you're working with
thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]